welcome to this new video okay let's buy
a form for a change against Horsehead
Nebula from please let it be Finland yes
I got a flag ride from Scandinavia
Finland I but I think finger does not
really strict this candy Naevia right of
you not very techincal about this okay
on Smith more arm for a change what is
the plan form maybe this is a fine go
water defense with with be 5 and so on
now it's been a while since I looked at
this book by mark SML really enjoyable
book about this opening I had a review
posted about hmm yeah I don't think it's
a year ago but maybe something around
that somewhere in the middle of 2012
yeah it's not them mmm that is
reinventing theory here probably e6 on
Knight f6 young why not night ethics
você não é 5 is not possible anymore I
think the question is this Queenie to
move that's probably Bishop g4 right now
I'm already irritated I don't want to
play h3 this really looks am like
complete complete nonsense hmm
there's a bear for maybe yeah come on I
don't know if I spend much more time I
probably will be close to okay well i
know i can maybe play edge three don't
mind that too much after yeah it looks
like him there should be a bit of a
compensation against the g6 bone Queen
g3 or something yep Queen g3 last night
h5
yeah move like g4s probably am
completely ridiculous yep probably it is
but there with earned with some slow
little move Son you probably won't Jam
have a great position as long okay this
was one idea
hmm yeah I probably can play you from 95
yeah this I didn't fear so much it's
maybe I'm okay as well but this i
thought i should i should have a bit of
something ham and this is a mouse club
queena three threatening g5 don't know
or g5 instantly yeah okay I'm opening up
my own team position as well okay
whatever
it looks like em I have some thread cm
may be here threatening 97 and how to
see protect f7 man Roxy Adam probably
needs the garage the eighth so Kim G
talking at kindred tool group h ones one
idea
94 maybe 90 force an annoyance iam I
come let's play justice it's not easy
for him to move his pieces anyway Knight
b6 that doesn't help
hmm
dad don't really see a good plan maybe
push before I for but this is a bit like
I don't know what I'm what I should be
doing to be honest it looks like yeah it
looks like white house Sam has something
in terms of compensation at least but I
don't really see a very clear-cut way to
proceed
yeah it's not so easy for black ass
while he's taking some time oh really
this is not protected
I probably doesn't matter a way that can
do here maybe Bishop 25 I tried to enter
on the seventh could be good
he can maybe take you now you can take
that take care of c-5 but the rook on g7
is not bad with us all kinds of chicks
coming Kim let's secure a bit look aged
three years I can go here look H wrong
not sure my am i mated on or not I'm
warning for them probably i am in some
way Jay
hmm check check check check check check
check check check check check we drawn
by repetition and feel I'm still lost ya
you have King h5 t h5 and Bishop age six
is the problem very lucky escape they
can can do that yeah and then there's no
check and no check means it's over yeah
I what a complicated position Oh funny
yeah yeah I'm winning what rock d6 yeah
I had a vague idea that I could do that
but it couldn't calculate with 17
seconds we call it a spin actually the
wake idea that I had was Queen here but
this is Susan speeds to made oops
ok
yeah this is funny that this is actually
winning okay yeah I've got lube g2g
seven coming and no way to prevent it
just an exchange yeah very very crazy
game all kinds of results were possible
i guess around here it looks like some
some nice position for white but it's
difficult to play and all kinds of
things can happen this is probably I
know maybe it's a mistake and giving
this up but yeah this is Luke Luke h4
yeah Black is goof around certainly yeah
thanks for watching